when Aldridge ruminated in the fading of
the fire and inspired visions of the
coming age of the deep sea he knew the
path would be arduous but he had no fear
he would devour the gods himself
let's take Aldridge of devouring men he
ate so many that he bloated like a
drowned pig then softened into sludge so
they stuck him in the Cathedral of the
deep and they made him a lord of cinder
north of energy but for mic'd to try to
understand Aldridge Sain of the deep we
must first gain a grasp on what the deep
even is from the deep protection miracle
the deep was originally a peaceful and
sacred place that became the final rest
for many of horn things this tale of the
deep offers protection for those who
worshiped admits these horrors the deep
was a tranquil site but was corrupted
and polluted by filth may have some
basis in the Shinto idea Kagari which is
a state of pollution in defilement
a spontaneous reaction to a moral
natural forces the word amoral is key
here since it dictates that intention
does not matter this is not an
equivalent to sin
it describes a desecration without moral
judgment it just is an understanding of
kagari
could lead to a better understanding of
the deep other miracles of the deep na
and Dory's gnawing inflict dark power
and insects upon opponents causing rapid
and copious bleeding the focus on blood
and insects further supports the idea of
kagura's association the deep as these
could both be considered a moral sources
of defilement but if the deep is such a
tainted and twisted place what kind of
wicked group would set up a place of
worship for it
in truth it seems that the cathedral or
Church of the deep
use these two terms interchangeably was
originally meant to seal away the
horrors of the teeth it was a sort of
countermeasure to the evil and darkness
that seeped out of the flue to deep the
Deacons of the Cathedral used items such
as the deep ring to ward away the
madness beckoned by the crow Ches
curries at hand and fortified themselves
with powerful cathedral knights which
served as strength against the repulsive
creatures of the deep the church was
assuredly at odds with this dark power
at one point in time however the clergy
in charge of keeping the deep at bay
eventually succumbed to their very power
it seems the need of tending the flame
north of faith could save them an
additional concordance with the Kagari
the deep corrupts purely by its
existence the intent of those who had
corrupts his meaningless the deep is not
corrupt out of any intent the cathedral
put itself dangerously close to this
corruption to try and fight it and fell
as a result due to the disappearance of
the only force that chose to fight back
the deep darkness from this great sea
has started to seep into lothric the
black blobs that explode out of the pus
and man's and you'd expend ear could be
a result of the heightened influence of
the deep blackness and evil
malformations definitely refer to either
what is referenced by the deep are found
in the abyss according to hawk would at
some point during the church's battle
and eventual submission to the deep the
man-eater Aldrich somehow joined the
ranks Aldrich began his journey to power
as a right and proper cleric yet he
began to consume men for unknown reasons
this bestowed upon him great power so he
continued to eat and eat until the point
at which he fattened like a pig and
turned to sludge it was at this time
that Aldrich was set into the church
around this time is also when Aldrich
became the saint of the deep and linked
the flame but you can't become a saint
by simply being powerful and joining a
church if it were that easy I think we'd
have a slight overpopulation of rich
Saints
no elders must have had a key role in
the church to acquire such a title I
believe that role had to do with the
defeat of the church at the hands of the
deep Aldrich was already considerably
tainted upon arriving to the Cathedral
of the deep the form we see him in both
the trailer and the game exudes a sense
of darkness and toxicity and this
gelatinous state is what would have
first appeared to the Deacons at the
Cathedral it would make sense that this
wicked beam powered by the consumption
of man did not facilitate the church's
battle against the dark deep instead
that most likely hindered the efforts of
the clergy and more likely seduced them
into succumbing to the darkness
Aldridge's presence alone could have
caused the demise of the cathedral or at
least enabled it but it would be safe to
say that the Lord of cinder
intentionally pressured and directly led
the congregation into siding with the
deep after all
Eldridge had visions of a coming age of
the deep sea when he contemplated the
fading fire why would he fight against
something he believed was inevitable it
would make more sense to accept the
reality of his visions and work towards
surviving the coming age rather than
desperately struggling to save a fading
one Aldridge would have used his power
and position as Lord of cinder to doom
the cathedral to lose their fight with
the deep so that he could secure his new
life in the impending age Aldrich left
the cathedral in this broken state
seeped in darkness to when the Bell
awoke the young kindled and the Lords of
cinder elders made his way to air tail
of the boreal valley Omri of astora
another on kindled seeking Aldrich
reveals this information saying
the man-eater must have left for his
true home the little doll in the empty
coffin told me Aldrich was said to hail
from Arizona in the boreal fattie
an ancient fabled City a pilgrim told me
that the city lies beyond firing key
and so becomes our destination it is
interesting to know that the armor of
anri's companion horace details how
Horace is one of the only two children
to escape Eldridge's clutches the other
beam honoring this along with some of
honorees of their dialogue paints a
picture how Aldrich must have set his
man-eating sights upon the home of
honoree and Horace only they escaped
likely swear in revenge upon the
wretched bean and attempting to exact
that revenge in their current quest this
reinforces the notion that Aldrich has
been eating men for years decades even
back to the scene of the deeps more
recent developments the small doll that
honoree mentions is found at the tomb of
Aldrich after defeating the Deacons of
the deep it reads in the legendary old
city of Erath hill situated in the
boreal valley the pont of Sullivan gave
this doll two valued subjects so that
they might use it to cross the barrier
when they returned home pond of Sullivan
is a mysterious and powerful figure with
too many lower implications to talk
about in just this video for now let's
focus on the fact that he controlled
Aerith Ville and imprisoned the god of
the old royalty in the abandoned
Cathedral to be fed to the devourer so
it seemed the reason the elders returned
to Aerith hill was the pontiff was able
to prepare him something much more
appetizing and just man once we step
into the fight against Aldridge Sain of
the deep and devourer of gods his second
epithet becomes clearly evident the body
of the last guy to reside in Anor Londo
the god of the dark moon gwyndolin
rests atop the dark mound of gelatinous
goop Aldrich what's worse is that
Gwendolyn is most likely being eaten
alive while the fight is going on
Aldrich's rings that drop from the deep
accursed
tell that Aldrich had the desire to
share
with others his joy of imbibing the
final shudders of life while luxuriating
in his victims screams these rings
display that Aldridge so thoroughly
enjoyed even his victims alive he
crafted rings to share this feeling with
others it can be confirmed that
Gwendolyn is the one who being eaten
here and that he was being mean slowly
because Aldridge's soul can be
transposed into the longbow of darkman
Wendelin who was gradually devoured by
Aldrich finally in the boss fight the
young Kindles targeter locks on to the
dark goop rather than the body of
gwyndolin which is doing the actual
attacking this further supports the idea
that Aldridge is really only the
gluttonous worm and Wendelin is still
being eaten he's not a complete part of
eldership another point of interest is
that the soul of Aldrich can actually be
transposed into two different weapons
the first is the longbow which has been
discussed but the second is a miracle
form of the life hunt scythe the weapon
of the crossbreed priscila from the
original Dark Souls was even more the
description of the miracle reads
eldritch dreamt as he slowly devoured
the god of the dark moon in this dream
he perceived the form of a young pale
girl in hiding this account matches up
with Priscilla so it appears that
Aldridge was able to copy a weapon that
he only dreamt of as there really is not
any evidence of him eating the
crossbreed and if he did he probably
would have the actual sight not just a
miracle version that he summons into the
fight only a couple of times when
altered ruminated in the fading of the
fire it inspired visions of a coming age
of the deep sea he knew the path would
be arduous but he had no fear he
devoured the gods himself Aldrich saw
the fading of the flame and the arrival
of a new age of the deep he tried to
prepare for the treacherous journey that
was to come a gaining power the only way
he knew how
consuming others yet he found men were
not enough Aldrich began his journey as
a cleric do not clerics worshipped gods
higher than men so Aldrich decided to
devour the gods
in the end though alert was never able
to witness if his new age would come to
fruition for as he consumed he was
consumed so the cycle goes yo what is up
everybody man luigi here and i take it
if you watch the video all the way
through and you got in here that you
must have really liked it so I
appreciated that and I'm happy that you
enjoyed it I want to make a little
preface if you have any questions
concerning any of these following things
that I'm gonna list hold back on them
just yet because I'm gonna be making a
video then releasing tomorrow that is
going to go over my basic ideas about
them so if you have a question about
Aldridge being small
Aldridge being the chosen undead from
Versalles one eldritch evening Neto or
the witch of izalith the deepest
connection with the abyss the tower made
in Gorka or pots of sullivan pulled back
on those questions and if you're
watching this a day from when i posted
it click the link that you can see on
the screen or i'll probably put in the
description as well for my thoughts and
views on that so you can leave your
comments over at that video
that being said again I want to say a
big thank you to everybody watch this
another huge shout out to redditor I am
NOT here or there there a person who
compiled a ton of Dark Souls 3 lore and
a lot of what I'm doing in these lore
videos is putting a lot of what they
posted into a video form so make sure
you go check out the reddit post if you
want more direct feeds to the lore stuff
they have posts on a lot of other lore
in Dark Souls 3 I highly suggest you
guys go check it out
I'll put the links to that in the
description below links to everything
that I'm gonna be saying in the
descriptions below if you haven't seen
my other lore video it concerns the
pillars of lothric the three structures
that supported lothric before the undead
curse broke out I suggest you go check
that out
if you enjoyed this and if you're here
I'm assuming you enjoy this and go check
that out and yeah I really appreciate
everybody that's watched this and I'll
be continuing to make more lore videos
so if you like this stick around I've
made a lot of Dark Souls 3 content so if
you like that so go check it out
and yeah I appreciate you guys watching
and see you later
peace out